c'est pas le taux de femmes mariole
alors bien bien dans nos poches a alors
ça c'est important parce que cyril il
passe son temps à vouloir me prendre
mais soudan majeur imaginons hop je suis
là alors là non à nantes à 1000 billets
à ça mais reina 9e billets alors là moi
non j'ai dit au micro je peux pas
franchement assez assez impressionnant
pas assez nos recettes sa tuque des
plages mais ouais en fait en fait vous
kiffez en fait à mais oui c'est les
sportifs sévère je peux te pousser un
peu pour moi aux ayants droit moi je
suis en train de travailler crimes et
ses yeux je te dis baisse les yeux
voilà bah là mais c'est le salon imagina
regarde je vais prendre ce billet alors
tu vas attraper le bus attention
attention d'ailleurs très bien à l'abri
à voile attention parce que j'ai appris
beaucoup
ah oui alors c'est bon alors j'apprends
comprend frérot c'est pas moi on trouve
toujours s'est pas montré c'est vraiment
de la merde ce décor bon les amis au
portugal avant de gagner mais c'est bon
on est d'accord ça casse il décore me
faire enlever les séries je suis désolé
cc lui un cessez de spams afrique mettez
une ba non c'est plutôt carrément greg
basso cela ne bouge pas dans la loge de
servir et de là et là est offert mois le
mariole parce que là il ya greg mêmes
akela à hello hello petit cyril il est
là et qui sait qu'elle a aimé voir cette
bande des patois à temps
voilà valbuena n'a jamais allé je suis
pas du tout content parce que mon bébé
tombé il est tombé ces deux bastions
s'est vite il faut le dire si la tpp et
gym direct et de notre vie tranquille on
y va tranquille voire voilà voilà voilà
rien je n'ai vu un pied voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà
mais madame annie lalet mais voilà voilà
voilà mais on rigole
alors j'ai appelé mon toutou les matin 7
heures voilà c'est 6h53 je gagne tous
les matins action vérité avec vous devez
envoyer cyril tu fais le jour
on met en réalité tu est fragile un
tapage et rajoutera casta et pour tout
que toi et on en voit on en voit voilà
voilà voilà c'est parti mon avis ça va
répondre assez vite j'ai vu une turbine
et non vous êtes un pétage que les biens
quatre valeurs qui ont le répondu que
malgré les deux pour xavi voilà alors
que mengele bouffon qu'est-ce qu'il a
vendu 10 tonnes la gueule bouffon parce
qu'à et il a répondu ne t'inquiète jarry
voilà donc à mon avis menace sérieuse à
moi